what better place to dream than in belly
[Music]
france is one of the most adored
countries in american media there are
entire movies devoted to the wonder and
romance of paris i couldn't care less
about my book tonight i just want to
walk around paris with you it's even
gotten to the point that just saying a
french word is considered sexy say it
again dexter
[Music]
this admiration of french culture
referred to as francophilia has a long
history in the united states started in
large part by this guy
thomas jefferson along with other
american elites embraced french art
cuisine and politics and an appreciation
of french culture became associated with
taste and class but america's obsession
with france is about much more than just
enjoying french culture this obsession
is full of elitism and to some it's
antithetical to the american way of life
so let's take a look at the movies and
tv that explain this phenomenon but of
course we'll make sure to keep it classy
not classy not classy at all day class a
french
classic
obsessing over france is not strictly an
american phenomenon countries around the
world idolize french culture france's
global allure even got me interested i
was supposed to take a trip to paris in
march of 2020 but my flight got
cancelled for some reason so
unfortunately i have no idea what france
is actually like i'm just left with a
lifetime of stereotypes of what it means
to be french i think you know what i'm
talking about it's not cool
[ __ ] off oh it's g it's unsalvageable
yeah it's french
really the francophilia from centuries
past has lived on to the present day and
has embedded itself into all kinds of
television and movies sometimes as a
passing comment and other times as the
entire premise of a show one of the
early pioneers of american portrayals of
france and mass media was filmmaker
ernst lubich whose films often took
place in paris but like most movies at
the time were filmed on sound stages in
hollywood his signature loopage touch
added an elegance and sophistication to
his portrayals of paris and he didn't
necessarily base his style on reality as
he famously said i've been to paris
hollywood and paris france and paris
hollywood is better lubitz perpetuated
the chic aesthetic of paris and that
tradition continued throughout the
golden age of hollywood even as the
hollywood studio system declined in the
60s and 70s films coming out of the
french new wave deeply influenced
american directors like martin scorsese
and warren beatty these french movies
challenged hollywood filmmaking and
narrative techniques instead of the by
the book shootouts at the end of
hollywood gangster movies french crime
movies like breathless don't have
shootouts at all these french films
brought a stylization to cinema that
unsurprisingly american filmmakers
became obsessed with so it only makes
sense that american media created
characters who want to be french or at
least attempt to grasp french culture my
french is
pretty good
so
i can order for both of us
american movies are full of french
wannabes in good fellas henry hill shows
a group of girls his expensive and tacky
apartment and one of them smells his
girlfriend's perfume
i love
french this is honestly hilarious she's
pretending she can tell a perfume is
from france just by smelling it as if
she's some kind of geographic perfume
expert this moment reveals another core
idea in america's obsession with france
we want to seem classy
oh look at you but as americans we're
often just posing we'll have the
uh
the
we can learn a lot about a character by
how they try to seem hip to french
culture in the departed colin sullivan
wants to climb the socioeconomic ladder
he gets a promotion an apartment by the
state building and a harvard educated
girlfriend so it's no surprise that he
tries to flex his highbrow understanding
of french cuisine yeah they get this but
they don't get duck large and yet he
doesn't quite pull off the performance
the script notes that he's drinking an
inappropriate wine that doesn't pair
with the seafood he ordered and when
they get an unusual dessert he reacts to
it in a particularly low brow way
exposing his south boston upbringing oh
so look i don't know if that thing moves
i'm gonna shoot it the american french
copycat is all over american movies in
ratatouille anton ego insults chef
gusteau by comparing his cooking to
american food suggesting he's not
legitimate enough to work in paris gusto
has finally found his rightful place in
history right alongside another equally
famous chef
monsieur boyardee
perhaps my favorite french wannabe is
calvin candy and django unchained he
wants to be called monsieur candy even
though he doesn't speak french and he
presents himself as a sophisticated
socialite one of his jokes makes fun of
the boston accent you can't imagine what
it's like not to hear your native tongue
in four years well hell i can't imagine
two weeks in bolster
this joke is at the expense of the
supposedly less civilized americans up
north but the irony of calvin candy's
persona is that in reality he's the
uncivilized one unlike the people in
boston he owns slaves there's a clear
disconnect between his classy
performance and his participation in the
barbaric institution of slavery and that
disconnect between classy perception and
unclassy reality is so well understood
that it's even become a meme you may be
familiar with this screenshot of calvin
candy laughing at his own clever but
hypocritical joke it has spawned memes
like this one the memes usually describe
a childish act like tapping someone on
their left shoulder but being on the
right and juxtaposes that childishness
with a sophisticated chuckle and a glass
of wine the joke is that the action
isn't classy at all it's actually
immature and it's funny to imagine
someone feeling clever or high class
when they're actually doing something
dumb i think this meme perfectly
captures the essence of americans trying
to be french in a way we're in on the
joke we understand the desire to be
french and we laugh at our failure to do
it america isn't unique in its love of
french culture many countries from
russia to japan have their own histories
of francophilia but what makes america's
obsession unique is how francophilia is
seemingly antithetical to the american
way of life america is not known for its
classiness it's known for being loud big
portioned and over the top this
contradiction exposes the other side of
america's obsession with france not
everybody in america wants to seem
french on the contrary some americans
have a problem with france i'm talking
about a little place called aspen
i don't know lloyd the french are
[ __ ]
to some americans france represents
romance culture and high class but to
others the same place represents
snobbery elitism and cowardice the
musical hamilton shows how thomas
jefferson's love of french culture made
him seem out of touch and he received
criticism for staying in france instead
of fighting in the american revolution
so in the same way that a love of france
shows a character wants to seem classy a
love of france can also show a character
may be removed from working class
america like when an mit professor
visits a bar in south boston i get your
beer
um not just a perrier
it's french for club soda if you
approach french stereotypes with a
cynical lens the very same things
americans love about france become what
they hate take the french new wave which
inspired filmmakers to rethink
conventional narrative storytelling no
shootouts no
payoffs
just
human beings
talking for a fan of the avant-garde
this sounds fresh and interesting but to
someone who wants a classic shoot em up
that sounds horrible we're making french
movies now that sounds like the
stupidest thing no shootouts their class
and sophistication becomes a weakness
not a strength which is most clearly
seen in the beloved american tradition
of poking fun at france for losing wars
bonjour
yet she's eating surrender monkeys and
of course we find another contradiction
here the movie braveheart can make that
classic joke about france the french
will probably to anyone with strength
but later on the movie can also subvert
that trope and celebrate france for
aiding the war of scottish independence
which may remind viewers of france's
similar support for the american
revolution because of the unusual dual
meaning of trying to be french the
implications of french obsessed
characters change drastically depending
on the context a character like michael
scott would love to come across as
sophisticated but for angela french
sexiness goes against her christian
values
[Music]
where the naked ladies dance really andy
it's christmas and you're singing about
nudity and france perhaps my favorite
movie that understands all the strange
american ideas of france is the very
underrated talladega nights i am a
french
you say you're french
we
no we are not french
we're american the movie stars ricky
bobby a participant in one of the most
american sports of all time nascar the
film lovingly showcases america's
enjoyment of thrilling races gaudy
mansions and mountain dew ricky bobby's
antagonist is the very french jean
gerard gerard completely embodies all
french stereotypes he's effeminate
sexual and of course classy it's a
hilarious setup because the film
understands how out of place a formula
one driver feels on a nascar track but
the film also admires gerrard in its own
silly way when he beats ricky bobby
america declares him the best at nascar
and he becomes a celebrity so like
france itself he is simultaneously
despised and revered and by the end of
the film his character gets an uneasy
resolution ricky bobby kisses gerard
which is funny but he resists gerard's
attempt at a second kiss a small moment
that is just a joke but the joke also
reminds us of america's ambivalence
towards their french counterparts
talladega nights brings front and center
the underlying tension within american
depictions of french culture in america
french culture is a classiness to strive
for and many characters hilariously fail
at achieving it yet at the exact same
time french culture is something to
avoid a weak un-american aristocracy we
never quite know what to expect from a
french reference it's as if france is
tapping us on the left shoulder but is
actually on the right
and it's in this constant tension that
american movies and tv feel obsessed
with france because that country has all
this baggage associated with it
at this point america's obsession has
mutated into something far removed from
actual present-day france france isn't
just rich elite socialites drinking
expensive wine it's a diverse metropolis
with people from all walks of life
americans are not in love with paris we
are in love with the idea of paris it's
embedded in our dna what's one of the
most famous american movie quotes of all
time
we'll always have paris
in casablanca paris is an idea not an
actual place they ever go to and the
paris that ernst lubich established in
his films is a paris similarly once
removed from reality and i'm part of the
problem i've talked almost exclusively
about american movies and i haven't even
made it to paris yet but i also think
that's kind of the point these movies
aren't about paris france they're about
paris hollywood and for some reason i
love watching movies where us americans
try and fail to embody french culture
what's more american than starting from
nothing getting some money and then
being unwilling or unable to pass as
upper class that's as american as apple
pie so the next time you inevitably see
an american obsessing over france in a
movie or a tv show think about how that
obsession says a lot more about america
than it does about france that's a
french-ass name ivan
yeah my little croissant little cheese
on my croissant
yeah
in reality the classiest thing you can
do is click the subscribe button or
support now you see it on patreon thanks
for watching and stay classy